♪ ♪
>> THE INFLATION THAT WE HAVE
SEEN WILL BE TEMPORARY, IT IS
NOT SOMETHING -- I EXPECT IT TO
LAST HOWEVER FOR SEVERAL MORE
MONTHS AND I FOR SEE HIGH ANNUAL
RATES OF INFLATION THROUGH THE
END OF THIS YEAR.
>> Tammy: THERE YOU GO, WHAT
SHE IS NOT TELLING YOU IS THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S TRYING HIS
BEST TO MAKE SURE INFLATION
ISN'T JUST A PHASE.
BUT THE NEW NORMAL.
THE PRESENCE PUTTING FORWARD THE
LARGEST FEDERAL SPENDING PLAN IN
HISTORY.
A WHOPPING $6 TRILLION AND OF
COURSE HE WON'T SEE ANY OF THEIR
MONEY, IN FACT YOU WILL BE MADE
FOR.
UNDER BIDEN'S PROPOSAL TRUMP TAX
CUTS WILL BE ALLOWED TO EXPIRE
IN 2025 IF THE CUTS AREN'T
REPLACED OR EXTENDED TO, BIDEN
WOULD BE BREAKING HIS PROMISE TO
NOT RAISE TAXES ON ANYBODY MAKIG
FIRE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR.
JOINING US NOW, DR. BEN CARSON
AND THE FOUNDER OF THE AMERICAN
CORNERSTONE INSTITUTE,
DR. CARSON, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING TONIGHT.
I THINK NONE OF US ARE SURPRISED
THAT JOE BIDEN IS BREAKING A
PROMISE.
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT ARE SAID
ARE LIKE FROM A GRAB BAG JUST TO
PERHAPS GET ELECTED.
THIS CLEARLY CAN BE TRAGIC IF WE
CONTINUE TO ALLOW IT TO UNFOLD.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THIS, SIR?
>> THE SAD PART TO ME, HAVING
SPENT MY ENTIRE PROFESSIONAL
CAREER AS A NEURAL SURGEON AND
BEING CONCERNED ABOUT THE
WELFARE OF CHILDREN.
THESE THINGS CAN BE DONE WITHOUT
CONSEQUENCES AND IT WAS
THOMAS JEFFERSON WHO SAID IT IS
A MORAL TO STEAL FROM FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE DOING,
CREATING MOUNDS OF THE AMAZING
DEBT THAT SOMEDAY HAS TO DO
WITH.
NOT ONLY THAT, BUT CURRENTLY,
YOU LOOK AT THE IMPACT OF
FLOODING THE SYSTEM WITH MONEY,
BUT NOT HAVING THE EQUIVALENT
ABUNDANCE OF SERVICES AND GOODS
THAT AUTOMATICALLY CREATE
INFLATION, AS FREEMAN ELOQUENTLY
TALKED ABOUT.
IT'S ALMOST AS IF WE HAVE READ
ALL THE BOOKS AND WE HAVE SAID,
YES, WE TOO WANT TO HAVE THE
SAME PROBLEMS THAT ARGENTINA HAD
AND THE VENEZUELAN SIDE, AND ALL
THE COUNTRIES WHO DID THE SAME
THING HAD SOMEHOW WE ARE GOING
TO BE DIFFERENT.
WE ARE SMART ENOUGH, AND I THINK
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN PERSON
KNOWS WE ARE CREATING A
MONSTROUS PROBLEM FOR OURSELVES.
>> Tammy: WE HAVE LIVED
THROUGH THE CARTER YEARS AND WE
HAVE SEEN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PRESIDENCIES.
WE HAVE SEEN WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT THIS IS NOT
NORMAL, THAT THE LEADERSHIP
MATTERS.
STANDARDS CAN BE SET AND IT'S
VERY STRANGE, FOR ADULT PEOPLE
MEN AND WOMEN, JOE BIDEN HAS
BEEN IN OFFICE FOR 50 YEARS NOW,
FOR THEM TO SUGGEST THINGS THAT
WE KNOW HISTORICALLY, THERE IS
NOT ONE SUCCESSFUL EFFORT TO
IMPLEMENT THIS.
THAT THE SPENDING OF MONEY IT'S
LIKE A MONOPOLY MONEY AT THIS
POINT LIKE IT IS WATER.
>> THAT'S CORRECT AND NOWHERE IN
THE WORLD, NOWHERE HISTORICALLY
HAS HAD THE BIG PUSH TO
SOCIALISM WORKS.
IT ALWAYS SEEMS GOOD IN THE
BEGINNING WHEN YOU STILL HAVE
THE MONEY TO DEAL WITH.
AS MARGARET THATCHER SAID, IT'S
GREAT UNTIL YOU RUN OUT OF OTHER
PEOPLES MONEY AND YOU WILL RUN
OUT OF OTHER PEOPLES MONEY
BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL PEOPLE
WON'T BE MAKING AS MUCH MONEY
BUT ALSO MANY VARIOUS SUCCESSFUL
PEOPLE WILL TAKE THEIR MONEY AND
GO ELSEWHERE.
IF THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED
IN FRANCE SOME YEARS AGO WHEN
THEY BECAME WILD WITH THEIR
TAXES.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED TO
US AS WELL, NOT TO MENTION THE
FACT THAT WE PUT A BIG STOP SIGN
ON THE MANUFACTURING AND SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE ARE DRAWING
PEOPLE HERE.
IT'S GOING TO HAVE A HORRIBLE
CONSEQUENCE.
>> IT'S ALMOST AS THOUGH I'M A
HORRIBLE THING TO EVEN CONSIDER
THAT THEY WANT THIS TO OCCUR.
WE WILL HAVE TO MAKE SURE THEY